has 2023 been to say the least a little
bit disappointing on the TV and movie
front let's discuss welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel what the point of recording this
and hopefully when you're watching it it
is New Year's Eve and at this time of
year of course we think about the TV and
the movies that we're going to be
looking forward to in 2024 but also the
year that's just gone by and I have to
say has it been a very disappointing
even mediocre year for the genre I love
the most science fiction well I had to
have a look and think about the movies
I've enjoyed this year the movies I
haven't enjoyed this year the TV shows
that have really impressed me and the
ones that just didn't and in all honesty
the list of films I really enjoyed this
year from science fiction is quite short
the list of TV series I've enjoyed this
year is even shorter there's a bunch of
stuff I'm okay with and there's a couple
of shows I've damn right
hated I've only been able to pick three
films really this year that I've
actually hand on my heart honestly
enjoyed the science fiction the first
film was on Amazon and to be honest not
many people watched it it was called
totally killer it was a slasher film
with um elements of Back to the Future
this woman builds a time machine she
goes back in time murder murder murder
hacky hacky hacky it's not the greatest
film ever made but why it's made my list
was because I was expecting nothing I I
was I was expecting a terrible movie and
actually it's all right um it knows it's
silly it plays with itself it has fun
and to be honest it's just a good silly
sci-fi film I actually really enjoyed it
God's Zilla minus one is another film I
have to say I absolutely adored
obviously this is a Japanese production
it's only about 120 Minutes long it is
completely out there um all of the
special effects it is it's absolutely
glorious to watch the special effects
are stunning if you actually want a
really good monster movie don't bother
watching monik that might be on the list
of things that disappointed me a little
bit this year hint hint go and watch
Godzilla minus one it is a genuinely
brilliant movie and you will be in awe
when you see it the bigger the TV you've
got by the way the more you're going to
enjoy this film The Last on my list is
no one will save you now this was again
a relatively small um Alien Invasion
movie it was not complicated there's
virtually no dialogue in the movie
virtually nobody says anything um but
it's just about aliens they invade and
then the story focuses on basically one
character in her little small town
desperately trying to survive it's it's
genuinely just one of those films that
was
simple it's not trying to be massively
clever it's just good I have to say
though that I'm really struggling to
pick any more sci-fi movies this year
that I've enjoyed I don't think Marvel
have particularly done anything I
enjoyed I didn't even really enjoy
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 it was okay
there was a few other movies at the cin
where I went to watch that again were
just okay it does feel that Hollywood
has lost some of its bravey in the last
couple of years it does seem that they
are so convinced with being for
everybody that all they're actually
creating is vanilla ice cream movies
that actually are bland and tasteless I
want to see a little bit more Rocky Road
ROM and raisin I want to see a little
bit more flavor to my movies but that
means Hollywood's got to be brave and at
the moment it's
not how about on TV TV because obviously
streaming all of that beautiful lovely
money going into the streaming providers
yeah I mean look for example at how much
monik cost now I normally say that Apple
do quality over quantity they create
really good television shows they don't
tend to spend too much money but they
did in this case they spent significant
budget each month they got big stars in
it again which is something they tend to
do anyway and they created a TV series
that is again good but it's not
great all the way through the series
they keep hinting at all these mysteries
from the Monarch's past but those
Mysteries aren't particularly intriguing
you're not desperate to find out what's
happening I found myself waiting for the
next Monster to turn up playing with my
phone occasionally enjoying Kurt Russell
in this role and his son Wyatt but not
loving it and to be honest that is going
to be be a theme throughout most of the
TV shows I'm going to talk about for
example Silo Silo was really good a
beautiful acting really beautifully
written and by the time you get to the
end for me I found myself not really
caring what was happening anymore season
two of the foundation came out again on
Apple and to be honest that was probably
my favorite proper Sci-Fi series this
year I actually thought that was
stunningly well made but again
I do find it a little bit hard work you
do have to concentrate on it I'm not
enthralled by it I'm not like
desperately waiting for it to come out
each Wednesday or whatever day it came
out and then you know getting up early
to watch I just enjoyed it it was okay
I'm looking forward to season 3 but at
no point did it really really excite me
or really get me or really draw me in
and that's what I really want from my
sci-fi I want to come away away from it
and be talking about it on this channel
I want to be talking about it to my
friends I want to be so excited by what
I've seen that it makes me think about
things differently none of these shows
did that this year Loki season 2 was
Marvel getting back to its best to be
honest I enjoyed Loki season 2 it was
interesting but all the way through I
was just thinking they're just trying to
wrap up the whole Kang thing just in
case that guy does go to prison which he
looks like he's going to and they've
sacked him now anyway I just really
loved Tom hudleston I didn't really love
the series The characterizations was
great but nothing really happened it
wasn't as exciting as maybe I was hoping
now one program I am looking forward to
for Marvel in the next couple of weeks
in fact is Echo now that does look like
that's got some excitement and I think
Marvel are now going back in the right
direction
but they did release the worst
television show possibly I've ever
seen secret Invasion it was and I'm not
meing my words here
awful now She Hulk came out at the end
of 2022 and I didn't like that either
but at least I could appreciate that
they were trying to do something
different with it they were trying to
have a show that was um very different
for them I felt like it was an interes
in business model to take the mick out
of your core fan base bit strange for me
but at least they were trying to do
something secret invasion was supposed
to be them getting back to their Roots
it was supposed to be a classic Marvel
series but it made no sense it was
incredibly boring and to be honest it
took one of the best characters in Fury
and twisted him about and made him look
like a complete idiot at times it was a
very strange series I didn't quite get
where they were trying to get at and I
really really think whatever they were
trying to achieve they failed miserably
this was not just one of the worst TV
shows of 2023 it's genuinely one of the
worst TV shows I've ever forced myself
to
watch now one TV show that was genuinely
good was the last of us I really enjoyed
that I have to admit I never really
played the game I'm not a big gamer but
I found the storyline intriguing I
thought it was very well acted I thought
it was very well written again I found
it a little boring at times but to be
honest when it got good it got really
good I'm really looking forward to
season two and I just think that was
really really good television but then
we have shows like gen V again it's not
awful it's okay they lost me in the
first two minutes with the blood and the
stabby with the blood and things now I I
actually I'm a fan of the boys but I've
started to get a bit disappointed by it
of late I think that is a show that
started at 100 Mil hour and it didn't
give itself anywhere to go so their only
way now of sort of keeping the audience
engaged is by continuing to shock us the
problem is I think that they're going
Beyond bad taste they're going into just
the vulgar and for me they're losing my
attention gen V again did exactly the
same thing it's started at 100 milph for
me and didn't give themselves anywhere
else to go it's a show I didn't get past
the second episode and to be honest I
won't be going back to and I'm not even
massively confident I'm going to be
going back to um the boys when it comes
back at least the boys though has
characters I want to see through I I I
enjoy watching you know Carl Urban is
just a legend he just is genv didn't
even have that so no it was a show that
lost me really quickly
the one show this year though that I did
actually get up early for and got
excited for was bicard season three now
strange new worlds if you're a regular
Sid trer you'll know disappointed me
massively two or three of those episodes
were just bad a couple of the episodes
were good and a couple of the episodes
were just there but Bard season 3 was
genuinely really enjoyable I loved it
but even that in hindsight was
disappointing it was very predictable we
knew exactly that the Enterprise D was
going to appear and we knew exactly
where it was going to be they built it
up but we all knew from the second
episode we all knew that this was going
to be the Borg from pretty much the
first five minutes of the episode I'm
not 100% certain the finale made massive
sense I'm not as sure the whole thing
with data made massive sense and I do
know the producers made several
continuity errors which were quite
irritating if you were watching the show
closely so even a show that I absolutely
adored in 2023 disappointed me so I have
to ask the question was 2023 just a very
disappointing and mediocre year I think
it was now there are some really
exciting things coming up in 2024 I'm
hoping they will disappoint a little bit
less and now I'm going to talk about
that in my next video but guys get into
the comments and tell me what you think
from a science fiction point of view has
there been anything that was been really
brilliant that really deserved our
attention there have been some great
shows personally I I love the Tulsa King
with Sylvester Sloan on Paramount that
might be my favorite show this year and
there was um that thing was it
Pokerface that was a genuinely brilliant
show that actually might even be kind of
sci-fi because she could kind of tell if
people were lying so I might even have
to put that in the Sci-Fi area if it was
if we can class that as a Sci-Fi it's
probably the best sci-fi this year Year
I'm not sure we quite can though but it
was a really really good show there is
some good stuff out there it's just an
our genre of sci-fi I'm not sure
anything's really stood out but am I
wrong get into the comments and tell me
what you have really loved this year and
what has just been okay what have you
hated get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com sidre where most of our new
videos premere first and you get to see
them without the adverts I don't know
why I just said first like that these
things happen when you're recording
finally you can go to c.co which is a
dedicated website where we do articles
based on a lot of our videos and we try
to add a bit more information for you to
digest go and check it out as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time